معنا الان من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس ارحب بك متابعتك لما
يجري اذا تحديدا في شمال القطاع ربما وهذه
الاخبار يعني على لسان كتائب القسام التي
تتحدث في هذه الاخبار العاجله عن استهداف
دبابات ميركافا صهيونيه كما تقول بقذائف
الياسين 105 ونضيف الى ذلك اذا الخسائر
المتواصله بصفوف القوات الاسرائيليه
هنا وواضح بان المعارك في المنطقه
الشماليه لقطاع غز محتدمه ومشتعل على اكثر
من محور وهنالك تحليق كثيف للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في سماء المنطقه الشماليه
تحديدا في الدقائق الاخيره رافقه بطبيعه
الحال قصف مدفعي شديد لاكثر من موقع
ولاكثر من مكان لكن واضح بان التركيز هو
على جباليا على مخيمها وعلى جباليا البلد
وواضح بان الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي يكاد
لا يغادر اجواء هذه المنطقه التي نقف
عندها في غلاف غزه والمطل على جباليا من
الواضح بان المعارك على اشدها هناك نلاحظ
ه سحب الدخان المنبعث من اكثر من موقع في
جباليا ومن جباليا البلد ايضا شاهدنا في
الدقائق الاخيره غارات جويه كبيره استهدفت
هذه المناطق وترافقت ايضا مع قصف المدفعي
وكذلك هو الحال ايضا مع الاطراف الشماليه
لمدينه غزه التي طالتها غاره جويه عنيفه
في الساعه ال الاخيره من الواضح بان
المعارك هنا لم تنتهي بعد والجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يحسم اي ال الميدان الى
صالحه رغم ادعائه بالسيطره العملات
والناريه على اكثر من مكان في شمال قطاع
غزه حتى ان المناطق الشماليه الواقعه على
الاطراف اقصى الاطراف الشماليه لقطاع غزه
اي بيت حنون وبيت لاهيا ما زالت هذه
المناطق تشهد ايضا قصفا مدفعيا شديدا
وكذلك
اشتباكات مسلحه اذا ما زلنا نسمع واياكم
هذه الطلقات المدفعيه سفيان ونشاهد هذه
الاستهدافات في الاطراف الشماليه الشرقيه
لجبال اذا اعمده الدخان تتصاعد بعد هذا
القصف المدفعي
وضوه المعارك
سفيان حقيقه ربما تدلل وتشير الى هذه
الارقام ايضا التي يتحدث عنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي حول قتلاه وجرحاه في هذه
العمليات الجيش الاسرائيلي اعترف في اقل
من 24 ساعه او اعلن عن مقتل 13 جنديا
اسرائيليا في كل المعارك ليس فقط في معارك
المنطقه الشماليه انما ايضا في معارك
المنطقه الوسطى وال الجنوبيه وفي اخر في
تحديث له ب حول عدد الجرحى في صفوفه هو
يشير الى ان عدد الجرحى بلغ
44 جنديا اسرائيليا اذا قصف مدفعي شديد
الان على جباليا وال المناطق الشماليه
للقطاع قصف متواصل ولكن سفيان هم يتحدثون
عن 44 جنديا جريحا لكن الاعداد التراكميه
على الاقل في الايام الثلاثه او الاربعه
الاخيره فاقت 150 جنديا اسرائيليا هذا من
حيث عدد الجرحى وطبعا هذا يشير الى ضراوه
المعارك والى قساوه وشراسه هذه المعارك
التي حتى بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث
عنها في تحديثاته وفي بياناته الصباحيه
والمسائيه على حد سواء الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي اشار
الى في اخر بيان له في مساء الامس عن
ان الانفاق الهجوميه هي التي تكبد الان
القوات الاسرائيليه ربما الخسائر الاكبر
في الارواح من حيث الجرحى والقتلى طبيعه
الحال هذه نقطه في غايه الاهميه على
اعتبار ان اسرائيل وان حسمت كما تتمنى او
تمني النفس المعركه على الارض او فوق
الارض فانها لم تحسمها او ما زالت بعيده
عن حسمها تحت الارض على اعتبار ان حتى
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه لم توفر
لها تقارير حول تشعبات هذه الانفاق
واماكنها وامتدادها واماكن وجودها وواضح
بان كان هنالك اخفاق كبير من ناحيه
ال الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
تحديد مواقع هذه
الانفاق الهجوميه وبالتالي هذا ما يكبد
الجيش الاسرائيلي الان خسائر حيث ان
الناطق العسكري يقول بان المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين يخرجون للقوات الاسرائيليه من
فتوحات الانفاق ويسدد ضربات مؤلمه وموجعه
لقواته نحن الان نشهد في الاجواء الشماليه
لقطاع غزه دخول ايضا المروحيات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على خط المواجهه مع قصف مدفعي
شديد حقيقه في الدقائق الاخيره ربما تسمع
ذلك سفيان والمروحيات العسكريه في اجواء
المنطقه تقوم بتوجيه زخات من الرشاشات من
العيار الثق قيل على المناطق الشماليه
لجبال كما
يبدو ودعنا نشير ايضا الى انه رغم كل هذه
العمليات العسكريه المتواصله القصف
المدفعي والغارات الجويه والعمليه البريه
المتواصله على الارض المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تمكنت في الساعه الاخيره من توجيه ضربه
صاروخيه لبلدتي عليم وبيري الواقعتين في
المناطق الشماليه لغلاف غزه وكانت هنالك
اعتراضات صاروخيه ايضا طالت هذه ال
المناطق هذا لليوم الثاني على التوالي
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه تشهد كل هذا
التكثيف للغارات الجويه والمدفعيه دون حسم
على الارض والمقاومه الفلسطينيه تتمكن من
توجيه ضربات للبلدات الاسرائيليه ضربات
صاروخيه للبلدات الاسرائيليه في المناطق
الشماليه لغلاف غزه ووصلت مساء امس حتى
الى الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه عسقلان التي
كانت تحاول ان تعيد مسار الحياه الى ط
بيعتها في الاسابيع الاخيره على الاقل على
مستوى جهاز التعليم لكن عمده البلديه وبعد
قصف المدينه ليله امس عاد وقال بانه سوف
يحدث تغييرات على منحى اعاده سلك التعليم
الى التعليم
بشكل اعتيادي وهذا من تاثير القصف
الصاروخي الذي طال عسقلان ليله امس و طبعا
هذه المدينه كانت تعرضت لاكبر عدد من
الصواريخ منذ بدايه هذه الحرب في السابع
من اكتوبر اذا الجيش الاسرائيلي بدون حسم
لا في المناطق الشماليه ولا في المناطق
الوسطى ولا في المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه
الذي قال بان خمسه الويه تعمل فيها وتنشط
عسكريا وكان رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هيرتس هاليفي قد قام بالامس في جوله
تفقديه حيث اجتمع مع كبار القاده
العسكريين الميدانيين في منطقه خان يونس
واشار الى ان العمليه تتقدم هناك بنحو على
نحو ممتاز كما اشار لكن واضح بان القوات
الاسرائيليه تتكبد خسائر فادحه بالارواح
وبالع تد و هاليفي ايضا اشار الى ان
العمليه العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه سوف
تتواصل وربما تحتاج الى كثير من الوقت ل
انهائها وهذا هو الحال بطبيعه الحال ما
نسمعه من ال المتحدثين السياسيين
والعسكريين في اسرائيل الذين يقولون بان
الحرب متواصله ولم تنتهي بعد وهذا ما كان
ايضا وزير او رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو قد اخبره ل الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن في اتصاله الهاتفي ليله امس وقال له
بان العمليه العسكريه في قطاع غزه سوف
تتواصل وهي متواصله حتى تحقيق اهدافها
الياس كرام من غلاف غزه اشكرك